now to california where multiple
wildfires are costing people their homes
and that includes the caldor fire which
more than tripled in size in just a
single day it already has destroyed
parts of the town of grizzly flats where
thousands were forced to flee overnight
our jonathan vigliotti is on the fire
lines in el dorado county that is just
east of sacramento jonathan good morning
to you
guys good morning to you we're on a road
that was an evacuation path and this
morning much of it engulfed in flames
this fire is dynamic it is fast moving
and it is unpredictable as these flames
driven by high winds are blowing
everywhere including the embers it
started yesterday as a spark it quickly
grew doubling in size to about thirty
thousand acres several towns remain in
harm's way including grizzly flats in
fact we're told that town of about 1200
people all but lost many homes destroyed
including the elementary school and the
post office these fires driven by
climate change and this morning fire
crews are losing the battle only about
250 crews are here on scene because
resources are stretched in as fires like
this burn out of control across the
state this morning in fact 120 miles
north of us and it's getting incredibly
hot where we are the dixie fire is
burning about 600 000 acres several
communities in harm's way including a
town of 18 000 people in just the last
year i've covered five towns destroyed
by fire the very real concern this
morning more talents could be added to
that list anthony yeah very scary
developments there jonathan be careful
out there thank you